Oh rattle rattle ride alright alright
alright alright so what's this 22:22
chasing geeks 22 so same old same old
if you like us on YouTube remember to
Like comment subscribe bash us love us
whatever all of that good stuff
mmm that could good if you just enter
the audio Spotify Apple podcast [ __ ]
Google parts whatever make sure you
subscribe so you get that auto download
and as of today this week whatever we
are officially on patreon so patreon so
if you want to be a patron make sure you
look up there's a lot of people in on
our page people don't know what it is
alright so if you don't know what it is
patreon is a little service in which you
can help us so as you know we are
starving eyes exploring our craft
yeah my staff and I so this is saying
that we want to do long-term as we've
said many a time and if you want to help
us do that obviously it takes funds so
we set up a little patreon account you
can go to patreon.com/scishow and gigs
that's SH and XTS gigs and that way you
can become a patron of the show there's
different tiers depend on how much you
want to spend and you get different
benefits so have a look help us out and
let's keep the pipe moving man just do
this full-time so without further ado as
part let's get into it so couple days
ago we got back from am said stroke the
babbling Villa like it was my birthday
on Monday so at the 17th whenever this
comes out it was on Monday but if they
wasn't Monday and me and the fellas went
to Amsterdam first time for everything
none of the group have been I think I
don't think any of the group had been so
yeah it was it was a good experience Jay
had been Joe had been Oh Jay had been oh
yeah of course
Jay and Jay is buns it was just
something that it's not necessarily my
Amsterdam was one of the place I wanted
to go but I just want to do something
like hi
in Europe with the fellas and Amsterdam
is why not it was an hour away it was
one of them it was less than less than
an hour it is quicker we found out
quicker to go to Amsterdam from
Manchester or London then it is to take
a train from Manchester to Milton Keynes
yeah it's crazy
that's mind boggling well it's
ridiculous so it was a good trip man
Shila no my highlight was so these men
were laughing I mean because I said the
best my highlight of the trip was going
to a museum so there's a museum called
moko Museum in Amsterdam I things like
south/southwest I'm not too sure but
it's in it's in Amsterdam Central and it
was because I was baked die enjoy I
thoroughly enjoyed it but that aside
because I had never been to
I hadn't been to museum since probably
uni or no uni so it's probably a
secondary school primary school for like
trips and stuff on trips so go into a
museum like it opened up different I
don't know you opened up something in me
because I'd never had that or felt that
experience before my life well I liked
it a long time clearly because I was I
was mesmerised some of the rooms were
absolutely crazy like so it's MOCA
museum it's essentially a house and
every every single room has been
redecorated into however like theirs
portrays the sculptures or the room
itself is engulfed in different lights
and different atmospheres and stuff and
it just it mentally bows you away it was
a real it was a really good day for me
man I was loved in life you were loved
and I was eight I was broke I was
jealous so I was obviously I've never
smoked I've never had edibles I've never
done nothing and this whole time
everyone's asking me like oh are you
gonna get high yeah and I'm like [ __ ] it
you know actually might yeah I actually
might yeah so my plan was and I spoke to
my boy by as well cuz I knew it can be
[ __ ] cold yeah and using me [ __ ]
cold so I was like I started to my boy I
buy it and I was like I'm not looking
forward to the cold yeah and he was like
now there's like something special about
going on a trip where it's cold yeah
especially for going somewhere Amsterdam
most coffee shops all over the place in
which you like it's cold outside so it
makes you want to be inside yeah and all
the things that you hate about being on
a hot holiday it tells what being inside
and stuff yeah
that you want to get out and about yeah
he's like you look forward to it on a
kadhai day and he's just like imagine
you and your boys all snug it up in this
warm spot because it's freezing cold
outside
mmm I never was just getting high so
obviously when we landed yeah you let it
day before us yeah when we landed out
for in my head all right cool so in your
instant story that you men were a coffee
shop anyway yeah pre dummy yeah so I was
like comp well buck these mind they're
got there obviously you weren't we
didn't even make it there we were on our
way there yeah when we bumped into you
yeah and you know we're done you were
high as [ __ ] so I was like there's no
way we're going back in there's no way
we're going your highest but there's no
way we're going back in there so yeah I
thought all right cool
pin til tomorrow and we're doing
tomorrow mmm tomorrow came I would I was
even hungover actually I was just
knackered yeah and then obviously we
didn't leave the hotel to Kosmos late
yeah it was pretty lit like four or five
in the afternoon and then again it
didn't it wasn't what the vibe yeah it
just wasn't
it had to be had been that day it had to
be in that day it had to be exactly the
way it was described to me in terms were
walking around the city yeah it's
freezing cold so much somewhere warm to
be going in and then there's a reason to
do I didn't want to travel out and be
like guys it's three o'clock let's go
get high yeah yeah yeah that's that's a
force yeah so long story short I didn't
get high the entire table is a monster
done put he's cool man lucky just I
really it's just not I don't think it's
me yeah I just don't think it's me to be
fair I never thought it wasn't me up
until I actually only sighs make it
which was when I moved there with Bella
and prior to that probably smoked a
handful of times but because of the lack
of consistency
I wasn't like doing it regularly of
course but now it's just now it's just -
me but the trip I had like the actual
mint the mental trip I had when I was in
pre dummy which is the coffee shop event
to have some if anyone listen to this
and he's going to Amsterdam I highly
highly recommend going to Frieda me as
PRI XD ' am i sand it's an amazing
coffee shop so it was me Tobes and the
other boy lolly so when we when we got
we've got one ready pre wrote and we got
a space cake
obviously then so we shared the spliff
but whilst I was having the spliff it
felt fine
only up until afterwards I was like okay
I could stop thinking it out I can start
feeling it out and when I say to you
James it was the best but scariest trip
I'll swear I've ever had look I don't
know because I felt like it felt like
ads smoked the whole spliff myself
that's the way I felt inside like my
body was all over the place and I it's
meant to relax you that's the way it
does it relax all your bones your nerves
it slows down your heart rate everything
but I thought I wasn't gonna make it
like I was rocking I was closing my eyes
I was perspiration bro that's a grab
dish from my pocket I just [ __ ] I was
lit felt as if I was on a on a ride and
I kept on going up and up and up and up
and up and when you think you've reached
the top yeah you're still going up
you're gonna take me hope that makes
sense I was thinking man damn you're
gonna have to take me home the lock of
the whole day I apologize but have to
sleep it off and they will reconvene in
a p.m. but I start slowly starts coming
down this the trip probably lasted five
minutes but it felt like eternity to me
yeah absolutely turn 80 so only God
knows how you might would have felt it I
was I was like oh my god and I spoke
regularly hmm what that was man seemed
fine they that's the thing that's why I
felt like I it must have like what's the
word I'm looking for
they must have faked it yes because the
way I felt was different in a way they
felt I wasn't done out here but once I
crossed that hurdle jump that hole it
was the rest of the day was the best day
ever you were loving life I was like I
was jealous like I said at the MOCA
Museum of so you know the story but you
have to climb a few stairs before you
get to the entrance so I was Misha at
the top of the stairs and then I was
looking back at the rest of them and um
and I felt like I literally felt like as
an escalator not escalate I felt like I
was on a ride you know when you're on a
ride where just before you tip over you
start going down you look back here you
see everything behind you that's what it
felt like to me and I felt like I was
gonna [ __ ] fall but I was so excited
hmm I was just
the best it was just the best cuz after
we smoked I was really high I was good
like I felt amazing
and then we bumped into you guys yeah
that was amazing times with that what
are the odds
yeah the odds we were because yeah that
was not even honest we bumped into you
in the middle of Amsterdam what are the
odds it's weird as well because
obviously like this is stupid and this
is out of it yeah but on the way this is
the kind of conversation I wanted to
have in a coffee shop right yeah so do
you ever feel like obviously in your
life yeah but you're the star of your
own movie na yeah of course so it's just
you mmm so me and Jay Jay is Jacob by
the way cuz I say Jay all the time I
don't people mind on that Jay Jacob came
on the podcast episode like 14
so me and Jacob we landed the day after
these guys and we were in the uber on
the way to meet you guys town so we're
in in the urban town and it's [ __ ]
packed like the streets up yeah yeah
like I don't know who dis not designed
Amsterdam but they designed it wrong
like Prague it's just it doesn't make
sense like this the pavements on the
road or one thing my cars are on the
pavement people are on the road like you
didn't make sense yeah but anyway so
we're driving I'm just seeing thousands
of thousands of people and like I'm
looking and I'm not drunk I'm not high
I'm not anything but I was just there
and I was like bro do you not think it's
weird like obviously I'm star of my own
movie yeah do you not think it's weird
that a couple hours ago we were in
England yeah and you just you don't
really think about it but as far as I
know I just see things through my eyes
yeah it's weird to think that like I'm
flying over here I'm in a different
country when I was England these men
would just live in their life yeah
they're all the stars of all the really
yeah yeah yeah how is it possible I'm
just like how is that possible
how can they be the star to remove I
know they might take yeah like will you
man here before I go is this true me
show yes who's the uber turns the corner
everyone just rushes out and it was and
I was like bro it's crazy it's like
what's that movie called with Keanu
Reeves this number two
the assassin movie oh don't make John
wick say I figured I think it's end of
number two where they're at the the park
bit do you remember when the guy says I
can make this stop whenever I want yeah
okay now everyone around him stop yeah
yeah bro
Matt so we were there I've seen always
hunter my man I was approached do you
not think this is weird like you just
live in their life and then there's
people in Bangkok living their lives as
how and I'm just like how how can
everyone have the same head that I have
and everyone's doing their own
everyone's got their own job everyone's
got their own relationships everyone got
their own problems as it's crazy and he
was he completely agreed with me
and then it goes back to like the whole
like life as a simulation yeah kind of
thing and then he said something that
I've never really thought about before
but he said like he reckons everyone's
everyone's in their own simulation yeah
so there'll be us in our simulation and
they're all the rest of the people kind
of lucky that are fillers but they
actually do have their own simulation
but the person that I'm seeing isn't
really them okay it's just their
simulated version okay so they are
living they are in Amsterdam and they
are walking down the same street yeah
but is that that's not there this is
just a shadow of what they're actually
doing okay and then he said like he
reckons the people that are in the same
simulation are drawn to give so the
people that are actually your friends
and your family and stuff like that the
reason you're drawn to one another and
stuff like that and people who
relationship with you because you guys
are in the same simulation yeah yeah and
then I was like okay interesting way to
put it yeah and then we bumped into you
like this all about this before the
conversation uber into town oh wow
isn't it for so five ten minutes before
we saw you he was like you're drawn to
one another because you're in the same
simulation and I was like you know what
when we saw you I didn't think about it
in two hurry the day after it was like
it aligned perfectly with what he was
saying because like I didn't clock
anyone's face yeah the whole time we'll
walk in this I didn't see anyone's face
but I saw you guys immediately yeah and
it's just like clang like there you are
like is like as expected yeah and it's
almost like there was like a space
around you there yeah yeah cuz it's
crazy because when it was obvious free
of us we were walking up the road you
were walking down the road and I think I
was talking to Toby I was on my phone
and then
we were obviously on the way to meet you
and inter was like our dead man I think
it would you mean there then one like
this isn't just like Manny you're
convinced your lund like we just bump
into each other bro
what you mean there they are look
something it's surely not and bro it was
crazy like for anyone is listening
thinking shut up like yeah you bumped
each other like I don't you might get it
like yes we were going to meet them but
I was going to meet them off a story
that he had uploaded two hours before we
were the Oberer driver had [ __ ] up and
actually dropped us miles away from
where we're supposed to be so at this
point we were aimlessly walking around
Amsterdam you man had a left where you
were supposed to be and aimlessly
walking around Amsterdam because we
weren't agreed to meet me anyway yeah
yeah and like it's crazy that like it's
like walking around London bumping into
something in his central London like
it's just there's not one street yeah
it's F is everywhere every which way I
can be was swayed ever another five
minutes we took a left turn or right in
bro we would have been ten seconds later
he would have been new would never have
never have happened
it was crazy yeah it was mad so yeah
that simulation tinctures it licked me
but yeah we went to a sex show I think
the sexual was my highlight really not
because of what you'd accept
I don't know I don't know if I think it
was my hand I think was just the most
unique experience yeah for me out of the
whole yeah okay okay so yeah we went to
this sex show and boy let's set the
scene it was in like a mini theater and
there was obviously a stage at the front
and tutors so we've got the people in
the ground floor and people above and
the bars up above as well and funny
enough J okay Jacob bumped into friends
that he hadn't seen in a while in the a
few to the section that was that was
also another weird coincidence
out of all the places to go up at that
time I've ever went answer them he
bumped into five people that you know do
you know what makes that more of a
coincidence why so when we were in the
airport yeah my man must have said to me
the last time he was in Amsterdam yeah
so when he signed with his record label
Interscope yeah he said that people from
the label they take you around take you
around so absolute I'm you go around
Amsterdam they show you the slide to
have a good time you do a show whatever
and then he said oh that's when he
because he'd been to that exact exchange
and he said that's they took him to that
so when we're in the queue to go into
again those are the people that took him
Oh mad so those are the people yeah so
the people he met are the people that
took him and obviously we saw dojo katsu
that's boyfriend yeah because he's just
signed with them they were doing the
exact talk again that's crazy man
yeah life is full circle that's man I
was like that's crazy crazy so anyway
yeah yeah queued up went to the sex show
and then we walked in there and there
was just two chicks suck enough a
double-ended dildo biggest thing biggest
thing okay okay sat down and then yeah
man people just just getting into it
yeah and then after that they had like a
little uh what was it what was next
it was the woman with the beads next
right yeah oh right so check this [ __ ]
out
and it was a there was a chick she asked
for volunteer one my man who was with
his girlfriend
rookie Errol why would he be lucky era
vaunted went up stage and got a lap
dance hall lap dances lap [ __ ] I was
done jealous I was [ __ ] just she
grabbed his dick hard and he was wearing
his leather pants as well we did she
grabs his dick hard and I was like [ __ ]
and then he's getting zapped us let's
that dance yeah blindfolded him
handcuffed him whatever and then she who
reached him between grabbed his hand put
it on her [ __ ] and then there was like
a little little bead one a singular be
singular bead hanging out so hardened to
grab that and then he was okay my girl
started taking back steps and these
beads are just a little coming out and
believe it or not what did she walk ten
feet away and feet away at least it was
a double dutch length yeah it was a
skipping-rope
it was a same vagina and it was just
there completely I don't know how I was
going in I don't know how she got it in
I don't know how she got in he was so
[ __ ] it off
and how is it so uniformed in there
because it must have been just like yeah
just whistled up oh and then yeah just
came out swinging it oh my it was
disgraceful but she in a wit in the
weirdest way she kind of made it sexy
yeah of course she played cuz if you say
it's not serious but you have to watch
it you have to be there she was she made
it work out she was the star of her show
when she made it work it looked good it
did look good reason I did so it was
like covering her nipples and into like
a thong kind of thing I don't know what
she did to it but yes you turn it into
this whole ensemble
it was buff so there was that what was
what I thought was that the gorilla went
after that
no before but in between the gorilla one
was just two people some people [ __ ]
yet but it was the they must have been a
couple oh yeah because they're weighing
golf dinner this is the thing as well
because I was on a rotating I was
expecting to go in there and when I saw
people [ __ ] I was robotic yeah and
they were just there going but these men
will go with it was they wanted it had a
connection and the fact that like it's
surprising how like erotic it is when
people who are [ __ ] you have a
connection yeah and people who were just
[ __ ] because the second couple that
would just [ __ ] yeah you could tell
it was just it was it was all a Sharad
yeah they were just [ __ ] yeah and
then they were just literally have an
intercourse yeah and these might have
sex and he did that cross leg thing he
did a new move when I saw that bro hey
can a bat I don't know who does this a
música for today to try this movie yeah
what did you do so she was less laced
picture she's on her back my man's likes
his knees it's kind of missionary button
there's no but on his knees to my top
right I'll Drive him yeah yeah yeah yeah
and usually yeah obviously grabbing legs
so my man made her cross her legs then
put his weight on her ankles slat and it
flattened it and then he was getting
[Music]
yeah
safer that move broke safer that move
you know what surprised me about
Amsterdam as well all of the like let's
call them sex workers so sex show people
escorts that we saw on dates with people
prostitutes in Windows all of them were
very [ __ ] good-looking yeah bro yeah
one prostitute in
window with the high-waisted ones who
was angry like I take another end yeah
yeah yeah I remember her darn it yeah
stunning stunning it's mad to me the
glasses I shall specs on I think no not
the Shorthair one nah nah I remember the
high-waist one she said [ __ ] you to the
guy cuz yeah he had long hair I'm think
I'm mixing two people in my stomach
yeah laughs stomach David and it was
oiled it was definitely all shining
she's just finished off of a client
probably you call me of God yuck Oh yuck
yeah they are banging they were bangin I
couldn't believe it
it's crazy I couldn't believe it was
hanging so the night before you guys
came oh us free went to the rent
electricity just to see what it's like
cuz we had never been do you know I mean
as soon as we bust that corner or you
sees red windows like red windows and we
just see titties ass everything so there
was one so it's relish tract is
literally a longer strip but it like
cuts off into different different modes
so we were we were look and explore in
all the roads and see where the scenes
were like and we bust down one road and
the amount of guys that were surrounded
one window was crazy to me so he walked
past it
it was the curly haired chick curly head
chick class is on mixed-raced
and like when I say she doesn't deserve
to be there like she was bangin bangin
like every man was looking at she was
she was like the belle of the ball she
was dancing in a window just like
soaking it all in comes me and then we
had walked past when we got any in the
road and we walked back and every man
was still standing it at least about 15
men worse than watching that window and
then one guy one black guy track see
bombs just wash fast everyone open the
door
exchanged worse and bald in every man
was contemplating didn't give a frog you
can tell you can tell man didn't from
Dipper [ __ ] it wasn't tell me I'm their
man I'm not from no it was wild
why don't I just explain it when you
guys describe that to me mmm and you
said like cuz obviously I thought for
sighs I thought the red-light district
was off ends
I thought you feel gone red light
district you'll get a taxi you telling
my manager take them to the red light
district completely and then it's just
that I didn't notice in town I didn't
know why just stumbling around in town
and then you just it's just a street you
know so anyway when you guys said to me
like ah one guy walked in and just like
destroy you just said that when you said
that to me the time I was like rags like
what's that yeah yeah obviously went to
[ __ ] like yeah yeah any man would do
that but when I actually saw them there
I couldn't imagine walking in with no
one's there yeah hundreds of guys roll
looking at you yeah I can't imagine
squeezing past guys opening the door and
be like I'm about to [ __ ] this girl like
the concept is why you concepts and the
confidence brogre and the confidence is
wild but like I can't imagine like how
to explain it like like I said to you at
the time like I just physically can't
imagine doing it mm-hm unless knowing
that she wanted me to do it yeah do you
know I'm saying like of course for
example like when we saw the [ __ ]
banging one that was just on about who
gave the guy the finger yeah if he put
his phone away mmm
went and said how much she would have
[ __ ] him of course but she hates me
hates him yeah it's stupid but she would
have [ __ ] him so it's just like I just
don't think that would be I just
wouldn't be able to get hard for it it's
like I wouldn't be exactly what you said
in a few episodes a few episodes ago
about five or six episodes ago I mean
you said you want the govern experience
with a stripper that's not your dancing
ability you don't have any dummy [ __ ]
you need to make it yeah let's make it
feel like real I'm imposing on your day
don't mean I don't feel like a regular
client yeah I wanna be the man I wanna
be the man like I wouldn't if I if I was
to ever get a prosecute you like I'd I
can't imagine what scenario yeah what's
an art have to be but like there's
always like how do I explain it like in
movies and stuff yeah in movies like how
to explain it like I don't even know if
this even is it James Bond film by I
feel like this is a changeup on film or
something similar where they're talking
talking talking flirt and flirt and
flirt in and then it's like
actually no no no no no no no no no no
no perfect example
I watched catch me if he can leave that
movie Leonardo DiCaprio I've seen that
seven times what should you have a day
and my man is in his hotel room and I'm
gonna have to do with this now [ __ ]
how he was the actress which one is
Jennifer Lawrence which was Jennifer
Lawrence no Jennifer Lawrence is from
[ __ ] thingy no Hunger Games from
Jennifer Lawrence she's from Elektra she
plays Elektra what's her name what's her
name what's her name what's her name
Bob I know exactly who is I know you're
talking about my wife I had going on
[ __ ] I can't move I know exactly you're
talking about though Elektra maybe
anyway the [ __ ] bad [ __ ] from
Elektra the shocking movie her she she's
of she pays like a model or sighting
like that yeah in a Jennifer Garner
Jennifer gone I knew thank God it was
Jennifer something and yeah she pays
like an actress or a model or something
like that yeah and then she clocks leo
yeah it says that your little Italian
sports car that he was rocking around
earlier mine's like years one of them
and then mine was like 17 she comes in
the room their lips and lips and lips
and lips in and then she's like ah how
much would you pay for me like if you
could buy me how much would you pay for
she asked him that she asked him that
how much would you pay for me and then
she's up for the whole night how much
would you pay for me and it's mad
because it sounded exactly the
conversations we'd have if I said how
much would you pay to [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah ridiculous woman so yeah how much
did you pay in my mind's eye I'll give
you like 100 and she's up now and then
deduct 200 now 500 now I grant and she's
like I cool I'll grant and then my man
like writes her a check it's just like
here's a check for grant puts it takes
it they start Lipson and they [ __ ] in my
head that's the way like a sexual
transaction a cz I want to [ __ ] you yeah
how like how badly do you want yeah
obtain me how bad did you wanna find me
do you want it I'm insane I'll pay a
grant a [ __ ] yeah
as you
all right cool grad let's give me the
grinder move [ __ ] like that in my head
that's the only possible way it could
ever happen is maybe I didn't even know
she was a prostitute before yeah well I
didn't even know like in the mood
fingers as well as like when we're just
walking cuz we left the club on the
Sunday yeah let me just walk in and
you'll seeing them come off shift and
you thinking why they're normal people
yeah that's the fan all the people they
normally they go home they don't live in
this little weird room they go by day
and I think like rock I like I feel like
I would rather I don't know I'm so hung
up in this
I would rather because I fight I think
the reason I'm so hung up it is because
I physically couldn't imagine when we
were there I physically couldn't imagine
any scenario yeah that consisted of me
going in there yeah yeah I couldn't
figure out yeah there was never it was
never gonna happen
yeah so I was like I can't imagine it
and then like when I saw him leaving I
thought I think I would even I would
even rather if I was just out on a night
out met a girl start talking talking
talking and I'm local so what do you do
yeah she's like I'm a prostitute I work
on [ __ ] Hoggard Street and then I'm
like oh swear and she's like yeah and
then we're joking around my what's your
running rate yeah this is like two bills
free bills whatever she says and I'm
like cool and then we giggle and go like
that's a perfect scenario yeah yeah yeah
so when you said now now that you're
telling me that one Donnie barged
through man I just witness I can't
fathom that
that's I said the confidence bro the
bravado it takes to do that is nice it's
crazy cuz it's nerve-racking it's I'd be
nerve-racked it's nerve-racking
I can do it I couldn't do it I couldn't
do it there's no way I'm getting hard
once we get in there there's no way
there's no way there's just no way Rob
is so scared bro the adrenaline goes
from here to here
he's crazy it's mad
and then I think like how the porn stars
do it I think it's just overtime in it
you get used to it because true I don't
know how I'd feel if people watching me
have sex like yeah same name it's it's
awkward enough when you is someone you
don't want to [ __ ]
maybe not necessarily awkward by so that
yeah you nobody put that MJ when it's
when you some more time you probably
don't want to [ __ ] and you've got camera
crew around you it's like what the [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] that takes balls bro
there's like balls to do that I can't
get my dick out on camera and be hard
and be harder for that long I think I
hid my head that they like chappie
oh yeah I'm also surprised that that
will scare the life I'm hoping a needle
in my dick I don't care how much you pay
me I'm not putting a needle in my
[ __ ] dick million pounds million
pound million pounds cash tax-free
million pound get this needle shove it
in your penis
inject it mm-hmm with this I don't know
if that's with this viscous liquid it
just it was gonna overflow does that
wonder oh oh oh it's gonna get you hard
then you have to have sex with someone
on camera on camera [ __ ] I would
obviously I don't know one I'm just
contemplate how horrific you'd be oh
it's already a yes for a million pounds
is very little I wouldn't do there's
very less I wonder for it's very little
I wouldn't do did I ever tell you about
the time I must I don't know if I said
on the podcast or whatever where there
was like a story about like these I
don't know if the Chinese or whatever
these manner just basically like
offering models and actresses like cash
like these Abu Dhabi man are offering
women cash to come over to Abu Dhabi
just for a weekend you may have told me
I don't know so there was a story out I
heard about it it's a story about this
girl who's like a monster works as a
model and then like she openly says like
are some guy in China or Abu Dhabi or
somewhere flew me out like on one-time
thing went through no no no no no no no
no I'm getting it wrong there's a
company that does it there's a company
that does it no that's just like the
highest end of
yeah so these aren't technically
prostitutes they're just normal people
yeah but the like rich guy
the billionaire whatever would be a
client of that company yeah and he will
say I want to [ __ ] Thanks whatever
[ __ ] Margot Robbie or someone
obviously Michael herb is never gonna do
it yeah just like a high-end model yeah
I wanna fly this person then the company
reaches out to the person I said okay
cool it's all safe is this and this this
guy's vetted like he's offered two mil
to fly you out yeah for the weekend
like fly you out for the weekend two mil
etc etc have his way with you my fly
back he got to me and your accountants
gonna go for us
he's going to pay for us we're gonna be
holding it yeah and then as soon as you
come back we'll put it into your account
and then obviously bear with him ever
been like yeah alright cool and it's
like we always talk about like our how
much to do this or how much to do that
how much do this they must be thinking
like alright cool two mil [ __ ] it I'll
[ __ ] this guy for to my probably a
picture finger [ __ ] it yeah I thought
this covered - yeah and I fought rough
they must land they're thinking all
right cool they get wined and dined
dinner fed everything bless man's like
shall we go upstairs yeah and she's like
yeah yeah yeah let's go upstairs
friend they must get upstairs and
there's like nine man in there my man
just dropped two mil yeah you know he's
doing dirt of course he's doing
everything you're not walking out of
here
me and her boys all right in a train on
me and the homies are gonna run a
[ __ ] train on you all weekend oh you
don't leaving it I hope you ate your
feel you ain't leaving it until Sunday
night they must be terrified oh my days
oh my days Rob because no-one's buff
enough for two milk mmm no-one's buff
enough for - one - no one's bought our
money mum ask money I don't get how rich
you are that's money here so if you're
doing it and you're dropping it you must
come through to the man like Drive drop
me 200k getting in this tray and they're
like yeah they get all the funds
together get the yeah over and they're
like babes they go we're gonna be
drowning in nuts oh we can pick a case
down bro I mean
these are gonna [ __ ] oh we're gonna [ __ ]
and then you can bounce with your team
ale that's correctly it happens though
innit
it happens a lot of people on Instagram
we are flown out a lot of people grow
how they do they [ __ ] do bury them
[ __ ] bury them and what's crazy is
that it were never well I don't know if
it will never happen for a guy but I
don't think it will happen for a man in
terms of women are always objectified as
sex objects like regardless of where
what you think about a woman you were
always objectify a woman one time at one
point in your life whether it be she's
walking down the street you just turn
around look out see if it's got batty
yeah if she's if she's a teacher
whatever you would object afire
somehow someway but a lot of women hate
it but within the same breath
if they got offered that same woman I
hate see if they got offered to milk it
will [ __ ] contemplate it of course it
was and it's like are you that strong of
a believer that you should never object
fireman Bratton to turn down to milk no
I'm not saying that no one it's morally
right or it's ethical but two minutes to
a minute within two minutes to much
everyone's ethics go out when it's
taught me longing table everyone's it
had about that free I'm doing it right
I'm not gonna live when when Abu Dhabi
hit me up like big man
hear me out listen don't block me don't
love him real talk he is too milk cash
goes like this on the camera but it's to
really cash you're a little sweet thing
my paramour sweet one you lower your
skin is soft let mouth fly you out it
Lisa
fab two milk let my fly you out why
aren't dine you treat you nice come some
more room me and the homies have a
little bit of fun and he did to new you
say it out loud
has made me regret saying it because I
don't think I'll do it as soon as you
said me and the homies will have a bit
of fun
never do it I should never do it
Monson me and the homies me and the
homies have a little fun
I couldn't slap and say cool I could
never do it fer me for a few hours and
bounce hours from the Train I couldn't
and it's to milf up nerve row already
he's already done said it episode like
three I can't get penetrated or episode
whatever episode it was like ah Thank
You laughs Thank You [ __ ] that was funny
I'm glad you didn't hear what I said hey
did you say something if you didn't say
I'm glad you to hear I said I wouldn't
have registered by me you said it I'm
joking I'm not doing noise I couldn't I
couldn't do it but you don't tell anyone
you would do it and not tell a song I'd
have to I'd have to tell song I couldn't
need my good cuz I have nightmares when
I come back I'd have to tell something's
don't have nightmares when I come back
nightmares a cat bear cast how it makes
plays about ready to bitters come come
oh geez I couldn't do it oh it would
traumatize me forever that's maybe so
hot
oh [ __ ] you know anyway let's wrap this
up my oh man oh Jesus